(audience applauds)
- All right, well, before
we close out day two
of premier week, I have
something exciting to share.
Y'all know, Karamo Brown as
an actor, author, activist,
all the A's and star of "Queer Eye",
but starting September 19th,
he will also be a daytime talk show host
and that is what I'm liking.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
It is nice to see you.
- Thank you, my love.
I'm super excited.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] I am so happy for you.
- Thank you.
- I mean, we were talking off camera,
I was asking, I was like, "Has
this always been a dream?"
- Yes.
- And you said yes.
- Since I was a little boy,
I used to tape over my
mother's soap operas.
This shows my age.
- Yeah.
- With her VHS with Donna Hughes, Oprah,
because I just love helping people.
It's the only thing
I've ever wanted to do.
And to be able to do
this five days a week,
having fun, helping people...
- Have a platform to do that.
Ooh, I'm in heaven.
- I know, I love it, I love it.
- That's more my kind of thing.
(audience applauds)
- Well, well, welcome to daytime.
- Thank you.
- I can't even believe I'm welcoming you.
I don't know, I just got here, but...
- This is the best welcome,
because you know, I'm a Kelly Stan.
- Oh my...
- Not, not fan, Stan, honey, Stan.
- I love it, I love it.
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
- I truly am so excited that
it's been a dream though.
That's, that's really cool when you,
when something comes to fruition
that you've had in your heart for so long.
So, what's your show gonna be like?
- So, my show's all about
regular people, everyday,
so anybody out here who has
a problem in their lives
with the relationship with
their mother, their father,
their boyfriend, their girlfriend,
if you need advice and you need
to figure out how to fix it,
come to the "Karamo Show".
- Okay.
- I've got you, I've got your back on it.
- Will you take celebrities
if they need help with that?
- I will actually, I will
actually take the celebrities.
Yeah, listen, listen.
- I'm like, "If I need help
with that, can I come?"
(audience and Kelly laugh)
Wait, I, I am liking this
post on @karamoshow right now.
(bell rings)
(audience claps)
I'm so excited for you, seriously,
from the bottom of my heart.
And with your show premiering Monday,
you're getting ready to
read a lot of teleprompter.
- [Karamo] Yes I am.
- And then you find out how
poorly you might be at it,
like I did.
(Karamo laughs)
So wait, do you wanna finish
out today's show for me?
- I will, sure.
- Okay, go.
- Can I have the honor?
- Yes.
- All right, listen, Kelly's
season-long, already started.
- Exactly, exactly.
(audience laughs)
- She said it, she said it, she said it.
- I know, I projected it, sorry.
- Kelly's season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
the makers of G-2, the
go-to pen of Kelly Clarkson
wants to honor truly unstoppable people,
like today's audience.
So, they've hidden a cheque for $1,000
under somebody's chair.
Y'all didn't know there was
money under your chair, did you?
- [Kelly] Seriously?
- All right, go ahead, take a look,
take a look, take a look.
(drum rolls)
- [Kelly] I love this part.
- [Karamo] I know, right?
Who got the money?
(Kelly and Karamo scream)
(upbeat music)
Congrats.
(audience applauds)
What is your name?
- My name is Aiza.
- [Karamo] Say it again?
- Aiza.
- [Karamo] Aiza, that's gorgeous.
- That's sexy, yeah.
- Right? Beautiful.
(audience chuckles)
Okay, so I wanna know what are
you gonna do with that money?
- Pay bills.
- Don't say pay...
- [Karamo] Oh, no.
- Okay, use a little of it to pay bills.
- Just a little, let me tell you,
the first thing you're gonna learn
on the "Karamo Show" is you've
gotta take time for you.
- Yes.
- You've gotta take time for you.
So, what are you gonna do with that money?
- Buy clothes.
(audience applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
- Yes, buy some clothes, have a good time.
- Thank you so much.
- [Karamo] You're welcome, you're welcome.
- [Kelly] You're gonna be great,
look how you just led her
to a better direction,
I love that.
Thank you so much.
- Oh, my gosh, thank you, my love.
- Oh my God, I'm so excited for you.
Don't miss the "Karamo Show",
premiering on September 19th.
Check your local listings
to find out where to watch.
Thank you so much, everybody,
that's it for today.